there's a fascinating fascinating line
of research recently trying to explain
why people see ghosts and it's a
phenomenon that people have talked about
for a long time that someone will
suddenly feel as if there's this
presence of another person that's near
bought and it turns out that you can
actually artificially induce that sense
of another presence that that's nearby
and you can do it
by using the sense that we have of our
own presence so as I'm sitting here now
I have a fairly strong sense that I am
sitting here now that there's this
person who's me who's sitting here and
part of that is because of my
kinesthetic appreciation of the way that
my own body works the fact that when I
tried to do something my body follows so
what they did in this experiment was to
set up a situation where when I'm say
touching moving a stick I feel a stick
behind me touching my back so even
though I couldn't actually be bringing
about that movement it's highly
correlated with my own movements the way
that my hand waving is correlated with
my intending to wave my hand so here it
is I'm intending to intentionally moving
the stick and I'm feeling the stick
moving in exactly the same way on my
back it turns out that when you do that
people report even though they know it's
not true they report that there's this
other person that's somewhere out there
there's a presence that's there that's
responsible for what's happening to them
and when you look at people who report
this feeling of presence it's a
characteristic of certain kinds of brain
damage which affect this kind of
kinesthetic sense we have of our own
bodies so the sense that I have that I'm
here inside of me not over there that's
generated by particular brain areas and
with damage to those brain areas that
that system gets sort of messed up one
of the results is that you think that
there's another person there now I think
part of what makes that whole story you
know you might think this is the kind of
encouraging you know scooby-doo sort of
story right so oh it looked like there
was a ghost but no no
we really found out that the ghost was
just this illusion of our own
kinesthetic body but even though that
seems kind of comforting I think there's
actually something even spookier that's
the result of that and the thing that's
even spookier is what about that feeling
I have about me what about that feeling
that I have that I'm here existing in my
body what these experiments suggest is
that's just as much of an illusion as
the ghost so the ghost in the machine
the ghost that's me that's just as much
an illusion that my brain is generating
as the ghost that's out there that's
that's causing that that feeling on my
back or the ghost that's out there
that's the result of the little glitch
in my kinesthetic processing so even
though I think this is kind of an
encouraging thought for Halloween that
all those ghosts are really just
illusions of your mind there's there's a
bit of a catch like in all good ghost
stories kind of turn of the screw that
says yeah well that might be true about
those ghosts but that might be true
about that ghost that's my own sense of
self to
you